[Musica]
pur amando molto i cani tratterò di un
argomento di animali in genere ma
particolarmente i cani tratterà di un
argomento che in qualche modo si
ricollega un trattato prima da un
precedentemente da un collega è
l'argomento dell'intelligenza
io però appunto ho detto prima sono uno
scienziato sono un informatico
faccio parte di quella categoria di
scienziati che fosse non è neanche tanto
considerato intelligente quindi non ci
prova neanche a dare la definizione di
intelligenza non definisco intelligenza
però seguirò un brevissimo percorso in
cui vi dirò che cosa noi vediamo come
vediamo noi appunto questa questione del
confronto tra l'intelligenza umana
l'intelligenza artificiale ovviamente
porrò un problema
definirò un problema infine chiuderò con
un esempio che ho appreso poche
settimane fa a pochi mesi fa e che mi
piace moltissimo quindi iniziamo
iniziamo dal fatto che alcuni scienziati
molto più bravi di me qualche tempo fa
iniziarono a parlare di singolarità
intendendo con questo termine
quell'esatto momento temporale in cui
l'intelligenza delle macchine avrebbe
superato l'intelligenza degli uomini
una volta definito questo concetto
concetto di singolarità si sono
scatenati di scienziati a immaginare
quando questo momento sarebbe arrivato
valori io voglio provare a darvi qualche
informazione per lasciare poi a voi
decidere se la singolarità è vicina
prossima lontana lontanissima
impossibile
le informazioni che vi do parlano di
macchine nella maniera con cui gli
informatici parlano di macchine gli
informatici parlano di macchine in
termini di algoritmi che cos'è un
algoritmo quando ho iniziato a studiare
queste cose trent'anni fa e per molto
tempo ancora un algoritmo era una cosa
semplice sembra una canzone ma era così
un algoritmo era una cosa semplice un
algoritmo da semplicemente una ricetta
per trattare dei dati
se ha allora b altrimenti c
se piove prendi l'ombrello altrimenti
lascia la casa
quindi ricette semplici per trattare
dati in una maniera con un'aura sopra di
imparzialità di neutralità che ha dato
in tutti noi membri dell'umanità grande
fiducia negli algoritmi
noi ci siamo fidati degli algoritmi e
gli algoritmi sono entrati nelle nostre
vite non sto a citare i milioni di
applicazioni nei quali gli algoritmi
appunto svolgono un ruolo importante e
ci accompagnano ma dalla medicina alla
finanza
la scienza ai trasporti ci siamo
affidati così tanto che abbiamo in tante
in tanti contesti affidato a loro il
compito di scegliere non sembri
esagerato quello che sto dicendo io
perché la vostra esperienza la vostra
esperienza umana quotidiana per esempio
quando andate da un dottore senza
offendere i dottori che sono qui è
un'esperienza algoritmica vi chiede di
sottoporsi a esami che restituiscono dei
dati dei numeri sulla base del riscontro
di quei numeri rispetto ai certi
parametri prende una decisione
lui prende la decisione in realtà la
prende l'algoritmo quindi noi ci siamo
innamorati ci siamo fidati degli
algoritmi e abbiamo affidato a loro
molte delle scelte che noi umanità
avremmo fatto fin qui come ho detto poco
male se un problema abbiamo rinunciato a
scegliere su cose su cui appunto ci
siamo fidati ma tutto sommato nessun
problema ma perché nessun problema
perché quelli algoritmi come ha detto il
collega che mi ha preceduto
erano nient'altro che la conoscenza
l'intelligenza se vogliamo dire che
colui che aveva scritto l'algoritmo
colui che lo aveva ideato colui che lo
aveva programmato aveva immesso in
quell'algoritmo quindi un algoritmo era
in qualche modo semplice pur a
conoscenza trasmessa da un essere umano
quindi perché non fidarsi se ci fidiamo
dell'umano ci fidiamo dell'algoritmo che
ha progettato umano fin qui tutto a
posto
però le cose cambiano cambiano a volte
anche molto velocemente
e cambiano molto spesso senza senza che
ce ne accorgiamo o con l'umanità un
pochino distratta cambiano attuale punto
che adesso nel mio settore si parla di
ag
agi significa artificiali general
intelligence non ho la pretesa quindi
fare una lezione su che cosa significhi
questa cosa strana ma proverò a
spiegarlo con pochissime parole
succintamente a partire da quello che
sicuramente avete capito essere un
algoritmo tradizionale cioè un oggetto
prima ne abbiamo detto assolutamente
hobby ed obbediente assolutamente
prevedibile assolutamente fotocopia
della conoscenza che l'umano aveva loro
trasmesso ora invece questi nuovi
algoritmi sono una cosa nuova non mi
chiedete perché come dal punto di vista
tecnico tecnologico questo è stato
possibile però quello che succede che
questa nuova classe di algoritmi non è
più solo conoscenza ma è conoscenza
unità esperienza cioè questi algoritmi
queste macchine sono in grado di avere
esperienze sono sottoposti possono
essere sottoposti quotidianamente a
migliaia decine di migliaia milioni
miliardi di casi di esempio da cui
imparano cose che non erano inizialmente
codificate nella conoscenza iniziale un
algoritmo moderno dunque un algoritmo di
intelligenza artificiale quelle cose che
chiamano deep learning machine learning
reti neurali un algoritmo moderno dicevo
non risponde più alla semplice equazione
algoritmo uguale a conoscenza dell'umano
ma risponde a un nuovo tipo di equazione
che è algoritmo uguale conoscenza più
esperienza esperienza condotta in un
contesto vasto come la realtà come il
mondo in cui viviamo bene se avete
capito la differenza se avete capito la
definizione probabilmente iniziate anche
a capire il problema tra un attimo birra
racconterò spiegherò il problema in
termini credo comprensibili ma siccome
professore universitario rimango minimo
20 secondi lo voglio fare e lo voglio
fare citando la sgridata che ho preso
quest'estate da un vecchio collega
americano che quando si rifletteva su
queste cose mi disse è marco come al
soul mi chiama giovane ma io non sono
più giovane marco come al solito voi
giovani insegniamo a voi giovani ma voi
se mi sembra che capiate ma dimenticate
tu hai dimenticato nel momento in cui ti
poni questo tema i nuovi algoritmi sono
qualche cosa di diverso dai vecchi
incorporano capacità di fare cose che i
primi non facevano e inizia a
preoccuparti insieme a tanti altri nel
mondo
hai mai dimenticato la prima cosa che ti
insegnano quando ti insegnavamo
cibernetica
la prima legge della cibernetica si
chiama legge di ashby dice che se tu
vuoi governare controllare un sistema di
una certa complessità devi avere a
disposizione un sistema controllante
altrettanto complesso del sistema che
vuoi controllare e allora lui mi diceva
ma scusa vi meravigliate adesso di aver
prodotto e di stare producendo sistemi
che sono gli algoritmi sempre più
complessi che prendono decisioni sempre
più complessi in contesti sempre più
vasti le cui conseguenze le cui
implicazioni possono molto spesso essere
impredicibili ma perché ti meravigli
avete creato state creando stiamo
creando una rete una sorta di realtà
parallela col controllante altrettanto
complessa rispetto a quella che volevamo
controllare
ecco dunque il tema ecco dunque il
problema se si pone una questione di
confronto tra l'intelligenza di queste
nuove macchine e l'intelligenza umana si
pone esattamente in questi termini
queste nuove classi di algoritmi
imparando dall'esperienza che fanno
tutti i giorni e non codificando quindi
più solo non avendo solo più dentro la
competenza la conoscenza dell'ingegnere
del progettista che le apre
dramma the possono avere comportamenti
impredicibili altrimenti non si
spiegherebbe la donna che andando in
bicicletta
circa due mesi fa in una strada del riso
dell'arizona in pieno sole è stata presa
sotto da una macchina guida autonoma di
huber impredicibili lim predicibilità mi
avvicina alla conclusione di questo
intervento
immaginando quindi che forse se c'è una
risposta a questo problema è una
risposta che riveda in qualche modo
l'alleanza parlo proprio in questi
termini quasi biblici
l'alleanza tra gli uomini e le macchine
per gli uomini e gli algoritmi dal mio
punto di vista da scienziato informatico
per esempio credo che se c'è una nuova
frontiera della tecnologia vi stupirò
quindi ma questa nuova frontiera e
l'etica non vedo periodo più fervido più
fertile più importante nel futuro per
una disciplina che non sia per esempio
la filosofia perché dovremo ridiscutere
insieme che cosa significa colpa che
cosa significa torto
che cosa significa intenzionalità che
cosa significa negligenza
chiudo con un esempio di una bella
alleanza tra uomini e macchine scendendo
un po dall'empireo o nuvoloso su cui ho
vissuto finora ad un esempio invece
reale guerra di siria tra i 56 milioni
di profughi 500 mila morti
i 500 mila morti contati che ho citato
sono morti per i combattimenti tra le
fazioni ribelle ribelli e le fazioni di
assad sostenute dai bombardamenti russi
in questa guerra in quella guerra tutti
hanno le mani sporche di sangue
anche gli stati uniti hanno ucciso circa
6.000 ribelli di isis tutti hanno le
mani sporche di sangue e
se parlate o se leggete articoli di
persone che vivono in quell'inferno che
hanno vissuto in quell'inferno narrano
che una delle cose più spaventose come
sempre per le guerre e se non altro per
le guerre moderne sono i bombardamenti
[Musica]
in questo momento in particolare c'è la
zona di idlib che è una piccola enclave
in cui si sono rifugiati quasi tutti i
ribelli e che viene bombardata
pesantemente dalle milizie as a liste
sostenute dai russi
si calcola che circa il 20 per cento di
coloro che sono in questa in club hanno
in realtà che fare con la ribellione
l'ottanta per cento sono persone normali
come me come voi e che quindi subiscono
i bombardamenti in qualche modo
ingiustamente rispetto alla propria
condizione di essere normali bene tre
attivisti prendono shazam shazam è un
simpaticissimo sono sicuro che molti di
voi lo conoscono una simpaticissima
applicazione di intelligenza artificiale
che quindi ha dentro tutti quegli
algoritmi strani che imparano e parlano
sempre di più di cui vi parlavo prima e
che riconosce una canzone
se vuoi entrate in un pub c'è una
canzone che non sentite lanciate shazam
e shazam vi dice di che canzone si sta
trattando bene questi tre a tre
attivisti hanno modificato shazam hanno
costruito una serie di sensori che hanno
distribuito nei boschi e nei prati nei
campi ove più possibile nella zona di
slip raccogliendo non più rumore delle
canzoni ma il rumore della guerra il
rumore dei bombardieri questi rumori
diventano dati che vengono raccolti da
un intelligenza artificiale che
utilizzando formule sofisticate di
fisica tipo l'effetto doppler mano a
mano che raccolgono dati imparano sempre
meglio per un bombardiere che sta
partendo sta passando in una certa
posizione dove andrà a bombardare chi si
collega a questa applicazione che si
chiama centri
può fare con telegram lo può fare con
whatsapp lo può fare con twitter
in questo momento a idlib a dieci minuti
per scappare prima di un bombardamento
questi dieci minuti sono valgono
l'alleanza tra gli uomini e le macchine
[Applauso]